Here are some common questions to ask when you
clean up data. Do variables have valid values?
Are numeric variables within range? Are there
missing values? Are there duplicated values?
Are values unique for some variables, for
example, ID variables? Are the dates valid?
Do we need to combine multiple data files? It
is important to check those questions and handle
them appropriately in the data cleanup process.
While it is straightforward to handle some of
those issues, dealing with others might not be
as simple. For example, handling missing values
usually requires good understanding of the problem
context and can take many alternative approaches.
There are many commercial and open source tools
for data cleanup. Two very popular open source
tools are OpenRefine and Data Wrangler.
The tools can greatly help many common
data exploration tasks. You are encouraged
to explore their websites to learn more.
Next, we move on to data transformation, which
usually means that we apply a mathematical
function to each data value. Perhaps
the most common data transformation is
centering and scaling of a single variable.
For those of you with statistics background,
you can think of it as calculating the z-score of
each observed value. That is, each data value is
first reduced by the mean and then divided by the
standard deviation. One of the immediate benefits
of centering and scaling is to make numerical
procedures easier to work with and more stable.
This is because the centering and scaling
ensures that multiple variables in a dataset is
on a common scale. Centering and scaling is often
required or recommended for some modeling tools,
such as clustering, principal component
analysis, and neural networks.
The main drawback is that the data becomes harder
to interpret. The data value after centering
and scaling measures the number of standard
deviations between each data point and the mean.
There are many other data transformations. Some
of them can be expressed using common mathematical
functions such logarithm, square, square
root, and inverse. Except for the first one,
all transformations mentioned here are considered
polynomial transformations. Because they involve
polynomial terms of the original data value.
Different transformations are appropriate for
different problem contexts. Sometimes, we have
to experiment to figure out the right one to use.
Each of those transformation can be easily
done in Excel and other data analysis tools.
There are ways to automatically determine the
appropriate data transformation from the data.
An example is Box-Cox transformation, which is
defined using a parameter called lambda. Different
lambda values give different transformation.
When lambda is 0, the transformation is simply
a logarithm transformation. When lambda not
0, it is a polynomial transformation with a
parameter lambda. For example, when the lambda
= 2, it is effectively a square transformation.
Note here that offsetting by 1 and dividing
by lambda does not change the distribution
of the variable. Similarly, when lambda equals
to a half, it is a square root transformation.
When lambda equals -1, it is
the inverse transformation.
Lambda can be estimated from the data
itself, and can take many different values.
In this way, this transformation covers
all transformations discussed before.
The transformations we discussed
so far work on a single variable.
This should be contrasted with data
reduction, which reduces the data
by generating a smaller set of variables.
The purpose of data reduction is to use a
smaller set of variables to capture most of
the information in the original variables.
A widely used data reduction technique is
principal component analysis, which seeks to
find weighted averages of the variables to capture
most of information which is measured by variance
in the data. The newly generated weighted
averages are known as principal components.
The principal components are uncorrelated and
ideally a few of them are able to capture most
of the variance in the data. An important
note here is that we need to first scale
the variables before applying principal
component analysis. This is so that the
principal components are not dominated by
variables that are much larger in scale.